en temps normal on est appelés pour un
décès donc on a une prise en charge de
tf1 qui se fait comme on dit à visage
découvert la prise en charge est tout à
fait classique sans précaution
particulière pour les qu'ovide c'est une
autre façon de travailler
on a reçu effectivement un dernier
décret qui nous a dit ben non les mises
en bière seront faites immédiatement sur
le lieu du décès et sans présentation
famille donc si vous fumez la prise en
charge d'un corps ça nous donne quand
même plus de travail parce que on est
obligé déjà de préparer le cercueil on
est obligé de partir le plus rapidement
possible puisque le délai donné par la
préfecture était une mise en bière dans
les 24 heures certaines maisons de
retraite ehpad ont mis ça à leur propre
sauce en fait ils m'ont dit nous on
préfère que les corps parce que
rapidement dans certaines maisons de
retraite où nous demandait de faire la
mise en bien dans les 10 heures